en ou 2019 ce duplex insalubres du
plateau-mont-royal a été vendu la ville
avait émis un avis d'éviction
neuf mois plus tard le voici en grande
partie rénovée il est maintenant en
vente à un million trois cent cinquante
mille dollars un peu moins du double du
prix ht
on sent que les quartiers centraux
effectivement la pression immobilière et
les très fortes ce printemps cet
arrondissement de la ville de montréal
ont adopté des mesures pour contrer
l'érosion du parc de logements ces
mesures varie d'un arrondissement à
l'autre mais vise principalement à
restreindre la subdivision de logements
existants pour freiner les éviction
abusive en l'empêchant de le faire de
plein droit parce qu'il ya toujours
moyen de le pas par une demande de
dérogation mais au moins c'est un
élément de plus qui va l'empêcher de d2
par une éviction
jean françois tremblay a acheté cet
immeuble il y a un an
il prévoyait le subdiviser ce qui lui
serait impossible avec le projet de
règlement ça fait ses quais on encourage
lors des gros logements qui vont être
obligés d'être rénovée qui dès à gros
volumes qui savent eux savent écouter
celle d'un logement de prometic aurait
montréal ce plateau
ces 5000 par mois l'entrepreneur estime
que la présence des optimisateur
immobilier est nécessaire la majorité
des logements que les occidentaux
récompenser des logements qui sont
insalubres faudrait qu'ils soient
rénovés selon la schl
le phénomène des flips immobiliers pour
les plex de deux à cinq logements est en
hausse mais demeure tout de même limité
par exemple de messages ça aussi autour
de 2% avant 2019 s'est un peu plus
fréquentes à trois points 7 % des
dérogations seront possibles mais pas
pour les spéculateurs
c'est pas lui qui va défendre quand on
défend notre monde sait les
propriétaires et les locataires qui sont
ici pour vivre ici ici marie josée
paquet comme radio canada montréal